back now on the ground things are
heating up in minnesota again tonight
mike tobin is there
with us for us mike
well sean it is heating up but it's a
lot of that pattern that we've seen with
the
bottles over the crowd the fireworks
going off and the police are trying i
just heard one of those projectiles
fired from the police
uh police are mostly trying to keep
these demonstrators off the fence and
we're about an hour
out of the curfew you talked about some
of the demonstrators who are out here
let me bring one in
this guy doesn't want to use his name
but his ex-navy says he served on board
the uss princeton
and what he's got here is a prop go
ahead and show the viewers
that is a uh that's a real pig's head on
a stick
with the cop hat on obviously you know
what that means first of all
why'd you put together this display well
uh i was out here last night
and uh i was simply over there having
some words with officers
somebody else uh shown a flashlight on
them
and i got maced in the face for the
second time by police officers in my
life
it hurt really really bad and um i got
really really nice
and i went and got this pig head in this
thing today all right go ahead john
sean's got a question
what about the people that are throwing
rocks bottles bricks
and other projectiles at the cops and
does he paint with such a broad brush
and
characterize all cops like pigs the way
he's holding up there
all right two parts to this question
first of all what about the people who
are throwing rocks bottles bricks
whatever at the cops
how is that different than what the cops
are doing in response
uh well we don't use tear gas we don't
use gas gases against the geneva
conventions it is harmful it's harmful
of course but that's that's the only
that's the only way they're going to
learn anything
it's the only way things could ever
change is if people start throwing
things and are you painting with the
broad brush when you do
bring out a symbol like this you mean
all cops are bad
i think the institution of policing is
bad there's probably some really good
folks i can see it in a lot of their
eyes
there's some good folks but they just
have terrible jobs what do you want
instead
uh an entirely different way of policing
i want
what is their badges and all of their
guns to stand down and to have this
building
so the entirely different way of
policing what do you mean by that i mean
some kind of community-oriented policing
me no i i'm not qualified to make that
decision but i know smarter people that
are
and it certainly isn't what we have now
well who are the smarter people because
we're not seeing that out of these city
councils
that's that's true you can probably talk
to them in this uh in this crowd a lot
of them are giving speeches here tonight
let me get your reaction as far as kim
potter she was released on bond today
the charge of second degree manslaughter
what do you think of rap mike
uh to me that's pretty much an outrage i
think that this lady essentially works
for a uh occupying force here
and she committed an act of war on
somebody i consider that an act of war
and she should not be out unbounded it
is not manslaughter it is an act of war
got it okay thanks for your opinion i
appreciate you keeping it clean
great coverage as always thank you